à 15 ans j'avais là me plaît et ma
plaine apporter du temps le vent de ça
tout ça lyon fc m'étais sauf d'enfants
à 15 ans j'avais des rapaces au zoo des
vieux et des grands je savais le faire
la chose la boîte de big cat
à 15 ans c'est henri van den heuvel fait
100 donets battre de la lame et
chandelles se savait si bien les aider
à 15 ans j'avais du panache et je
n'écoutais que ma voix à 15 ans faudrait
que l'on sache qu'on n'est jamais
heureux
kan souhaite
à 15 ans j'avais la mollesse des
contradictoires souvent je vendais ceux
qui se détestent je détestais ce qui se
vend
à 15 ans j'aimais la ripaille le corps
d'une un fokker d'oiseaux et tout ce qui
fait qu'on se taillent que la veille et
repas du morceau
à 15 ans
c'est henri van velde les belges de nuit
sont venus battre du sila des chandelles
mais lui ne me redonner à 15 ans c'est
l'heure où les veines s'apprête au
festin des rois ne savais pas que la
mienne commence et a pensé à moi
à 15 ans elle a mis s'élève sur mes
lèvres et son corps dessous
j'ai vu comme un bas de fièvre ce qui
n'était qu'un bain de boue à 15 ans je
le chasseresse elle a couru dans mes
buisson et si j'ai plus dre sa tendresse
ce qu'elle accuserait
chanson
à 15 ans
c'est henri bambelle que tous mes
rallyes seront donnés ce n'est le
collège font d'elle une autre maman
super à 15 ans on croit qu'on arrache
l'amour comme une fleur un beau à 15 ans
faudrait que l'on sache que l'aurore se
lève tôt
on
maintenant ma vie est petit
et petit aussi mes amours moi qui vivais
beaucoup trop vite mais henry donne sur
la cour
maintenant qu'elle a mis la patte sur
mes yeux mes rêves et mes fleurs il faut
bien que mon jeu ça bat par des optiques
elle coupe à coeur
maintenant c'est henri bambelle tous les
jours ces titans du collège et son aile
pour brûler les oiseaux de nuit
maintenant il faut que je cache l'amour
quand mon coeur désarmé à 15h faudrait
que l'on sait qu'une femme ne perd
jamais